hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video and today I just want to say happy
4th of July for all the people who
celebrated that yesterday I hope you all
had tons of parties and ate a lot of
food but if you didn't whether you're
out of state or you just didn't feel
like celebrating I hope you had a good
day anyway but also this title that
you're noticing is really shitty and
it's also a placeholder I can't exactly
come up with an idea for this maybe I'll
keep the title maybe not but if you have
a better name for the series leave it in
the comments and I might talk about it
in the next video but basically it's
about how where I go and ask the
question did or did this season or how
did this season impact for honor for
example we're going to be doing season 2
and I'm likely going to be doing one for
season 3 but like I said the title it's
super garbage maybe it could be better
maybe it's the best I can come up with I
don't know hopefully if you guys have
any better ideas for that or any
thoughts on season 2 and how this is all
going to plan out would then just I'd
love to hear them in the comments so
let's get started from the beginning so
to start off in season two we had two
new characters in two new maps Centurion
and shinobi were released along with the
Maps temple garden and forge at the
start everyone kind of thought shinobi
was the problem with his super safe kick
and his insane attacks too fast for some
players to handle but after a couple
nerf shinobi might still be difficult to
fight but he's okay for most players I
don't know about you but that's just a
personal preference for me I have no
problem fighting Shinobi's but I still
have problem fighting Centurion
Centurion though is up next everything
was okay with him for a little bit and
then people realized that he's got
incredible CC power and a stunlock
ability right and he's basically a
walking tank this became a huge problem
for players as he would destroy your
health within a few seconds by either
putting you against the wall or
continuously hitting you and not being
able to block the next attack because
that's stunlock ability and it sucks
imagine being a new player you drop for
honor season one you like you know what
season two is coming up maybe she
changed who knows we'll give it a try
we'll give them one more chance and you
come back into the game to get gank
squatted by a group of roaming
Centurions that just that's
heartbreaking that in my opinion is why
most players were completely turned off
from season two that came back or played
at all you know
whether you came from day one and then
quit then I think that's the reason why
most players uninstalled or stop playing
the game next to that we had new
executions that were leaked and
everybody was hyped for them they still
have yet to be released
sure they following that leak a small
patch came off of the DLC characters
which included making shadow Bishkek a
little bit less safe and guaranteeing a
combo off his long-range guard break
making it actually a little bit viable
and making Centurion less of a tank and
hopefully trying to balance him out by
increasing the stamina cost of his kick
in making these heavy attacks a lot
slower after that kick but as we all
know that didn't actually happen in fact
I'm pretty sure even until now nothing
has been really changed with Centurion
that has tremendously impacted him he
still is a high tier character and he's
probably likely going to say that way or
on the same time the devasting form that
there was going to be buffs for all
samurai characters except shougo key and
shinobi they didn't state exactly what
they were going to be fixing but Ubisoft
was open to listening to us the
community on changes a very skilled
Orochi player that was in the season 2
premiere tournament norscot June I've
talked about him a couple times may be
known from Dark Souls videos he had to
jump down immediately onto this topic
and typed off paragraph after paragraph
of info on Orochi and how to fix him
he's very good at Orochi he's definitely
I'm pretty sure he's max Rankin he's one
of the vestal roaches I've ever seen in
the game so if anyone's going to really
listen to it they're gonna listen
anybody it'd probably be him but he
recently uninstalled the game a couple
days ago because the dev said still
haven't said anything about the release
date of the buff or probably didn't even
bother to look at his list of ideas at
all he's coolly fed up and decided
enough was enough and then just left if
you want to hear more on this story
though I'm on why for honor and like his
whole story about leaving for honor and
the missed potential of it you can go
check the description and go watch it
it's a pretty lengthy video about 20
minutes it's long but it's pretty
informative so set aside some time this
today or this weekend go watch it it's
definitely worth the watch trust me
you'll enjoy it moving on next the devs
head stated that they were going to
issue a quitter penalty into the game
and this got people super excited that
maybe this would cause less server
outages and disconnects but so far it
hasn't helped much at all players are
being or players are reporting that
they're being stuck in the game not
being able to move and stuck in the
birdcam view when you like how when you
respawn and then when they quit the game
they get the penalty because they had
other choice but they either leave or
stick with it for 20 minutes on top of
that there was also talk about a ranked
muttered around this point enabling for
honor to spark a competitive scene but
at the at this point in time there was
no details as of yet and in the weekend
following that the infamous warden
one-shot glitch was found and damn did
people hop on this question abuse the
[ __ ] out of it also amid a video on this
glitch and it is actually my most viewed
video ever reaching I think 54,000 views
so they did everyone that watched that I
really do appreciate that but anyway
luckily that was fixed within a day or
two and Ubisoft did state that they
would ban people who have used the
glitch but I'm not exactly sure if they
actually went through with it or not a
week later the community went on another
blackout which some people defended in
some people didn't the people that
didn't create that didn't go with this
decide to make their own and call it the
whiteout and that sparked a huge
argument reddit unread and turned into
an absolute [ __ ] show every post on the
subreddit was dedicated to either one of
these two sides but when it came time
for the actual why don't I believe June
17th these servers ended up crashing on
all platforms basically and were unable
to be played until the day after
basically wasting people's time for the
White House and then finally to conclude
the video we had the release of the
public test just recently about maybe
four or five days ago for PC and judging
by the gameplay and feedback I've been
seeing of some very good players and
reddit it seems to be going actually
very well decent queue times to find
games and the player skill was on par so
that Pro players aren't exactly getting
matched with new players just getting
the game so the rank system is okay and
the ranking of progression is stable and
working is corrected for example for
example it could have been like oh you
win a game you only get 1% but when you
lose you subtract 10% of your rank
luckily it's all based off and it's very
even and it's all balanced the only
problem people do tend to have is the
waiting in between matches because they
carry on with the tournament every
player has to finish their match against
the other player and that could take
from a minute to an hour it all depends
on how slow the matches go with the
queue times and such like that so that
is the only problem but there really
isn't a way to fix that since you have
to have all players present but that
seems to be the only problem and it's
really not that huge in my opinion
though I think for honor season to hurt
game more than it helped them but who
knows maybe later down the line this
season they could turn around or maybe
season 3 will be that saving grace that
the game needs so now I've passed on the
question to you guys what do you think
about for Aundre season 2 what did you
like about it what did you hate about it
what do you like to change I would love
to know also so I guess for the lack of
for honor content this week there wasn't
much news and I was I have been playing
the lawbreakers beta a bit since it was
in beta although it did finish just this
morning so don't worry about that if you
don't bother watching lawbreakers I'm
not mad I respect that but I will have a
dead Street cat video for you all
tomorrow to watch so be on the lookout
for that
but anyway guys like the video if you
did enjoy this like it if you did and
subscribe for more from our content like
always and I'll see you all tomorrow and
peace out